So, my boyfriend and I work together
quite a bit.
Hey babe, can I get a neck massage?
Oh, sure.
(RWJ gags)
Just kidding.
(softly) That's only a daydream...mmm.
But we did have a business meeting
with someone a while ago,
when THIS happened:
To get you an initial treatment.
(farts) Excuse me.
Anyway, from there, if you like..
We didn't say anything at the time,
and in fact, as the meeting progressed,
we actually both ended up forgetting about it
until later that night.
During the meeting, did he...fart?
Oh my god, yes! But I wasn't sure
because he just totally shrugged it off!
I know, right? I was like, "Wait a second,
did that just happen?"
If it had been me in that situation,
I would have been all...
And then, if we--
(farts)
Um...
I, um...
Oh my god, I'm-I'm so sorry,
please don't--I mean, I'm so--
It's okay, don't worry. It happens.
You don't understand...
I can't let you live with this memory...
(sobs) I'm so sorry I died this way...
I was really looking forward
to doing business with you!
I was so blown away.
By how confidently he handled...
farting.
I mean,
I want to be able to OWN stuff like that.
You know? Just do what you do
with confidence and no shame?
Everything looks good here,
I think we just have one more business matter
to attend to.
(gunshot)
(screams)
Excuse me. As I was saying...
But yeah, it was just..
really interesting, seeing
how differently people
carry themselves.
And how you would approach
like, what could have been a really
embarassing situation.
So...thank you, business man
I will not name.
For inspiring me.
By...
farting. (snickers)
That is definitely a first. Aah.
I will see guys next Monday.
(slowly) Stay...
Awesome...
Nope.
Are you actually gonna choke me?
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
I'm gonna choke you so hard...
If your pressure is here,
(laughs)
RWJ: It's an actual choke!
Anna: Okay. (laughs)
RWJ: So, don't actually choke me.
Anna: Okay. Woops~
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara